हेलो गैस वेलकम तू युटुब चैनल अकादमी मेरा
नाम है आयुष पाठक और आज हम लोग कंटिन्यू
करने वाले हैं नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी वाली
सीरीज को तो दो क्लास में ऑलरेडी हो चुकी
है दो लेक्चर अपलोड हो चुका ऑलरेडी
नेटवर्क सीरीज का तो उम्मीद करता हूं वो
आपने देख लिया होगा पूरा इस वीडियो को
देखने से पहले अगर आपने नहीं देखा है तो
पहले इस वीडियो को अपडेट कर लीजिए वरना ये
वीडियो डायरेक्टली समझ में नहीं आएगी ठीक
है पहले दो वीडियो में थे सेकंड वीडियो था
इस वीडियो में भी थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकल होगा
और धीरे-धीरे हम लोग की तरफ और बढ़ते
जाएंगे ठीक है लेकिन जितनी भी इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज हैं उनको हम लोग कर देते हो चलेंगे
ताकि प्रैक्टिकल जो भी कर रहे हैं उसके
पीछे कॉन्सेप्ट क्या है वो आपको समझ में
आता है ठीक है तो आजकल नीचे शुरू करते हैं
पहले मैं मोडल ओपन कर लेट हूं
यहां पर आपको मिल जाएगा नीचे नेटवर्क
फंडामेंटल्स वाला ये रहा
तो इसमें से स्टार्टिंग
में अच्छे से
तो आज हम शुरू करेंगे
हम अपनी प्रेजेंटेशन का भी इस्तेमाल
करेंगे ठीक है और जितनी भी चीज एक्स्ट्रा
बताऊंगा ठीक है तो स्टार्ट करते हैं
सबसे पहले आप लोग की जो भी आप लोग पढ़ रहे
हैं उसका नोट्स बनाते रहे हैं ठीक है ना
अगर आप नोट्स नहीं बताना है तो आपको थोड़ी
सी प्रॉब्लम होगी हां कई लोग होता है
रिवीजन के लिए पढ़ रहे होते हैं तो वो
नोट्स नहीं बनाएंगे तो भी ठीक है पर आपके
पास एक शॉर्ट नोट्स होना चाहिए ना ठीक है
बट वास्तुन्नव बनाया कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
पर एक शॉर्ट होना चाहिए हर चीज का मतलब आप
चीजों को एक दूसरे से कनेक्ट नहीं करता है
ये मैंने जो दो दिन तीन दिन रुक के घर को
लेक्चर ए रहा है तब उसको कनेक्ट नहीं कर
पाएंगे आप भूल जाएंगे तो वो आपका खाना
चाहिए ठीक है ना चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं
सबसे पहले बात कर लेते हैं पैकेट और
फ्रेंड्स की ठीक है इस रूम को आपको मेरे
साथ करना है जो आप वीडियो देखने होंगे तब
तो पैकेट और फ्रेंड्स क्या होते हैं तो
पैकेट जिसमें मैंने आपको क्वालिटी राहत है
की कोई नेटवर्क है मां लीजिए उसमें दो
डिवाइस है ठीक है वो डिवाइस जो है वो एक
दूसरे को कुछ डाटा शेर कर रहा है डिवाइस
के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है तो
मैंने आपसे कहा था की वो स्मॉल चेस में
डिवाइड जो है डाटा सेंड होता है जब वो
वैसा ही मॉडल पढ़ रहे थे तो मैंने आपको
बताया था उसे टाइम की जो डाटा होता है वो
स्मॉल स्मॉल चेस में जो है सेंड होता है
तो उसको हम का सकते हैं पैकेट या फ्रेंड्स
ठीक है अब जैसा आपने बोला वैसे ही वीडियो
है कॉन्सेप्ट था यानी हर एक प्लेयर जब आई
रहती है तो अपनी कुछ ना कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
जोडी है करती है और वही रिवर्स होता है
ठीक है
ना एक-एक इनफॉरमेशन जो है हट्टी रहती है
फाइनल आपका डाटा जो मिल जाता है तो
स्टार्टिंग में मतलब हम का सकते हैं एक
तरीके से की पैकेट एक जैसे यहां पे भी
दिया है वही चीज लिखी हुई है तरीके से की
एक बड़ा जो एनवेलप है वो पैकेट है ठीक है
और उसके अंदर एक और अपने उसका फ्रेम कर
सकते हैं तो वही चीज है ठीक है और लेयर का
कॉन्सेप्ट
डाटा ट्रांसफर हो रहा है वो एक पैकेट जो
है वो एक-एक चैन को डाटा कंटेन कर रहा है
ठीक है अलग-अलग अमाउंट कर रहा है ठीक है
इस तरीके से जो डाटा को नेटवर्क में
ट्रांसफर हो रहा है वही चीज यहां पे लिखी
हुई है जैसे यहां पर देखिए एग्जांपल है की
आपका यहां पर पैकेट बन गया है जिसमें ये
बिल्ली का जो है पैकेट तू गया है बिल्ली
का पेट क्या है पैकेट 3 बिल्ली का पर है
ठीक है और यहां पे जाके जब वो फाइनल
कंप्यूटर में पहुंच रहा है तो जा के सब
कुछ जो असेंबल हो जा रहा है और फाइनल पुरी
बिल्ली यहां पर पहुंच गई है तो ये सिर्फ
एक डायग्रामेटिक प्रेजेंटेशन है लेकिन यही
चीज आपके मन का जो कॉन्सेप्ट होता है उसको
क्लियर करती है की ऐसे कैसे छोटे-छोटे
इससे हमें जो है फाइनल ली वो सबका सबमिशन
हो रहा है ठीक है ना तो इस तरीके से आंसर
होता है वही चीज यहां पे लिखी हुई है नया
नहीं लिखा हुआ है
आगे बढ़ते हैं
तो यहां पर इसे लिखा हुआ है डिस्क्रिप्शन
है तो जैसा मैंने आपको
बाढ़ रहे हैं ठीक है आपका अलग-अलग एड हो
रहा है इसमें अपने-अपने हर लड़की सबसे
अपना कुछ ना कुछ इनफॉरमेशन जो है उसमें एड
हो रही है तो हाइड्रो ही होते हैं ठीक है
ना मतलब कुछ छोटे मोटे इनफॉरमेशन होते हैं
लेयर्स के बड़े में या उससे रिलेटेड कोई
चीजों के इनफॉरमेशन होते हैं ठीक है ना
जैसे की एग्जांपल हो गए आपके टाइम तो लीव
ठीक है टाइम तो लाइव ऐसा हेडर होता है
इसका टल भी का सकते हैं ये कैसा हेड है जो
एक एक्सपायरी सेट करता है एक स्पाइस सेट
करता है अब कैसे सेट करता है जैसे मां
लीजिए टल वैल्यू आपकी फाइव है ठीक है ना
कोई पैकेट मेरा ट वाली फाइव समाज लीजिए और
आपका जो डिवाइस है उसने एक पैकेट में
वैल्यू फाइव सिटर के आगे भेज दिया उसे
पैकेट को तब वो पैकेट आगे एक दूसरे डिवाइस
किया अगर वही डिवाइस तो उसको पूछना था तो
ठीक है अगर उसे पे नहीं पूछना था तो उसकी
ट की वैल्यू एक कम हो जाएगी यहां से कर हो
गई ठीक है और फिर वो पैकेट आगे फ्रॉड हो
जाएगा अब दूसरे टाइप से पूछा अगर वहां से
पूछना था तो ठीक है उसका डेफिनेशन नहीं है
फाइनल है तो फिर से एक वैल्यू कम हो जाएगी
जीटीए 43 हो जाएगा अब फिर अगले डिवाइस पर
भेज दिया जाएगा ठीक है अब फिर अगले चला
गया अब अगर ये फाइनल डेस्टिनेशन है तो ठीक
है अगर नहीं है क्रिटिकल लुक फिर एक और कम
हो जाएगी ऐसे वो कम होते होते जाएगी ठीक
है और फाइनल अगर डिटेल वैल्यू जीरो हो
जाति है किसी डिवाइस पे आके तो उसे टारगेट
कर चुका हूं वहां पे वो खत्म हो जाता है
वो पैकेट वहीं पे डिस्काउंट हो जाता है
ठीक है ना ये कॉन्सेप्ट था टाइम तू लेफ्ट
का अब इसको करना जरूरी है वरना एक पैकेट
जो भेजो गया है अगर वो अपने डेस्टिनेशन के
बीच नहीं कर रहा है तो वो जिंदगी भर पैकेट
जो है ठीक है तो उसे दिक्कत होने लगेगी
भीड़ हो जाएगी उसमें तो इसलिए टाइम के लिए
इस्तेमाल करते हैं हम लोग इस तरीके से एक
चेक सा मटर होता है चेक्सम एक तरीके की
इंटीग्रिटी प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं आपके अगर
पैकेट में कुछ चेंज हुआ है तो चेक हमसे वो
चेक हो सके ठीक है भाई कुछ इसमें चेंज तो
नहीं किया गया है कोई इसमें कुछ तो नहीं
है ऐसा कुछ तो नहीं है करप्शन तो नहीं है
मुझे चेक करने के लिए इस्तेमाल किया जा
सकता है ठीक है सोर्स एड्रेस चीज है की
कहां से आपको पैकेट ए रहा है ठीक है और
डेस्टिनेशन कहां को जाना है तो डेस्टिनेशन
जरूरी है ये बताओ समझी रहे होंगे लेकिन
सोर्स इंटरेस्ट क्यों जरूरी है एड्रेस जो
है वो इसमें जरूरी है की जब किसी डिवाइस
पे कोई डाटा भेज रहा है अगर उसको रिप्लाई
करना है तो रिप्लाई किधर करेगा उसको अगर
आप अपनी भेजना है कहां करेगा इसके लिए
जरूरी होता है ठीक है
क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं क्या है व्हाट इसे
डी नाम
ठीक है
एक जो एडिट कर सकते हैं ठीक है पैकेट हो
गया
ये तो जब अभी पुरी फंक्शन एड नहीं हुई थी
तो उसको हम फ्रेम का रहे थे ठीक है अरे वो
और लेयर्स में जो है आईपी एड्रेस
इनफॉरमेशन एड हो गई तो वो पैकेट कला रहा
है ये चीज है ठीक है ट्रक्स वाली चीज अगर
आपको टर्म्स पूरे एग्जैक्ट नहीं तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं होती है उसमें क्योंकि आपको
ज्यादा प्रैक्टिकल होना जरूरी होता है
लेकिन आपको चीज पता हनी चाहिए होता क्या
है ठीक है चलिए टीसीपी आईपी और शिव के
बड़े में ए जाते हैं ऑलरेडी मैंने आपको
बताया था की किसी भी अप में अंतर क्या
डिफरेंस क्या है कैसे और चेक होता है सारे
फ्लैग कलर मैंने आपको बताया था आपको याद
होगा तो एक क्विक रिवीजन कर लेते हैं यहां
पे वही चीज देखिए
वही चीज है की ये गारंटी करता है
इंटीग्रिटी मतलब
सेंड हो रहा है ठीक है तो उसके बीच में
होता है जाता है तू पैकेट डिसेंट हो जाएगा
ठीक है लेकिन डाटा फाइनल पूरा पहुंचेगी
वहां पे इंटीग्रिटी जो है डाटा की मेंटेन
रहेगी सही से डाटा कंपलीटली पूछेगा बीच
में बिगड़ नहीं जाएगा की वही चीज लिखा हुआ
है यहां पे लिखा है ठीक है वो भी सही है
और वही है की लायबिलिटी यदि होती है
डिसएडवांटेज वही है मोरल स्पीड का ये ठीक
है
स्लो कनेक्शन वही चीज वहां से किसी के
बड़े में जो मैंने आपको सर बताया था अब ये
किसी भी पैकेट कंटेनर क्षेत्र इनफॉरमेशन
ठीक है ये टीसीपी के कुछ एड्रेस के बड़े
में है वही चीज घुमा फिर के और यहां पर
देखिए कुछ नया टर्म इंट्रोड्यूस हुआ है
पोर्ट मैंने इतना कुछ बताया नहीं बताया था
इसीलिए नहीं बताया था की पोर्ट आगे उसे
होगा तो हमें बताएंगे उसको ठीक है तो
सोर्स कोड डेफिनेशन
होगा ठीक है ये सब आपको मैंने लास्ट
लेक्चर
यह लिखा है की कैसे जो है हंदशके मतलब इस
तरीके से यह है की जो हेडर है ठीक है वो
ड्राइविंग करता है की पैकेट कैसे हैंडल
होगा ठीक है ना वो चीज लेगा मतलब से साइज
सेट है की एक फ्लेक्स है वो चीज है मैंने
आपको बताया ऑलरेडी फ्लैश के बड़े में दिया
हुआ है आपका से स्लैक मैंने बताया था आपको
सिर्फ मैच करने के लिए सिन का आता है इसके
बाद फिर ए खाता है इसके बाद मैंने आपको
तीन चीज बीच में जो भी ड्राइव ट्रांसफर हो
जाएगा ठीक है सीन जो कनेक्शन आपका कंप्लीट
हो चुका है सर कम आपका हो चुका है तो फिर
फिनिश होगा ठीक है गलती से कनेक्शन हो गया
आपको कनेक्शन नहीं करना है
ठीक है
एक ही बार में ठीक है
कैसे कम कर रहा है
क्लोजिंग का कनेक्शन
क्लोज कैसे होता है
कनेक्शन को कंप्लीट जब हो गया आपका कम सर
जो आपका आंसर हो गया है तो सीन पैकेट का
इस्तेमाल होता है मतलब कैसे हुआ देखिए
पहले यहां पर सीन हुआ ठीक है स्नेक हुआ एक
हुआ कनेक्शन स्टेबलाइजर ठीक है दें बीच
में आपका डाटा ट्रांसफर होगा अब आपके डाटा
ट्रांसफर शुरू जितना डाटा भेजना था पूरा
जा रहा है डाटा ट्रांसफर आपको कंप्लीट हो
गया पूरा सर्वोत्तर से भी क्लाइंट से भी
जितना कम्युनिकेशन राहत है वो हो गया अब
जब और करना है तो एलिस ने बॉब को फाइन
बजाओ की भाई फिनिश करोड़ कनेक्शन तो बॉब
ने भेजो ठीक है ठीक है भाई तुम्हारा बात
मां गया अब मैं अपनी तरफ से सीन भेज रहा
हूं अब वो अपनी तरफ से सीन भेज रहा है और
लेडीज उसको भेज रहा है क्या हुआ सीन किड
नहीं भेजो सरवर ने एक और फिर दो जी फिर
ट्रंटर वापस मिल जाए उसे कैसे का ठीक है
ना इस तरीके से कनेक्शन है
यहां पे क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं व्हाट इस
डी हैदर हेडर इन एन टीसीपी पैकेट
कम होगा
आंसर अपने से करना है वरना ये देखने को
मतलब नहीं र जाएगा ठीक है ना तो प्रोवाइड
डी ऑर्डर कैसे
होता है वो कुछ इस तरीके से होता है
हेल्प कम्युनिकेशन
[संगीत]
ओके गुड बाय ठीक है
इसके बाद डाटा जो है ट्रांसफर हुआ डाटा
ट्रांसफर होने के बाद कनेक्शन जो है फिनिश
हो गया जी तरीके से यहां पर हुआ था इस
तरीके से और ये आपको क्या मिल गया इसका
फ्लैग सॉरी इसका फ्लैग कॉपी कर लेते हैं
फ्लैग को यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं
ये आपका हो गया
इस तरीके से छोटे-छोटे
व्हाट टाइप ऑफ कनेक्शन यूडीपी स्टेनलेस
और प्रोटोकॉल वीडियो उसे तू ट्रांसफर फाइल
ट्रांसफर
चाहिए आपको आपको वहां पे स्पीड इंपोर्टेंट
है
ठीक चलिए
एग्जांपल आपने बहुत जगह सुना होगा जहां आप
अगर रिपोर्ट्स के बड़े में आपने कभी
समझाया किसी लेक्चर से आप किसी और से तो
मेरे ख्याल से आपने कभी नहीं सुना होगा तो
ये कार्यक्रम एग्जांपल है अच्छे एग्जांपल
है तो मैं भी उसे समझा रहा हूं आपको मिल
लीजिए आपका कोई घर है ठीक है तो उसे घर का
जो एड्रेस है करके एड्रेस को आप आईपी
एड्रेस दे सकते हैं ठीक है इधर का जो आपका
एड्रेस है वो आईपीएल ड्रेस है अब उसे आईपी
एड्रेस पे मतलब नीचे आप किसी को समझदार
करना है तो आईपी एड्रेस पर पहुंच गया ठीक
है अब वही मां लीजिए आप हॉस्टल में र रहे
हैं तो वहां पे आपका और भी कुछ बन सकता है
या ऐसी चीज भी मैंने रखती है ठीक है तो
उसको आप का सकते हैं पोर्ट नंबर ठीक है सो
अगर किसी पर आपका आईपी एड्रेस तो आपके घर
से पहुंच सकता है पर किसी के पास अगर आपका
पोर्ट नंबर है तो वो समझ सकता है की घर के
कौन से खिड़की से जाना है कौन से रूम तक
जाना है ठीक है वो उसका पोर्ट डिफाइन करता
है अब कर सकते हैं तरीके से मतलब अगर
एड्रेस आईपी नंबर है तो गेट नंबर या रूम
नंबर आपका पोर्ट नंबर है ठीक है इस तरीके
से पोट है तो आपको एक और आइडिया मिल गया
होगा फिर भी मैं इसको आपको अच्छे से समझता
हूं ठीक है देखिए बोर्ड ऑफ कंप्यूटर में
टोटल अराउंड यहां पर जीरो से लेक ठीक है
पोर्ट नंबर जो है वो जीरो से 65000 35 मिल
जाते हैं ठीक है इतने पोर्शन नंबर आपके हर
लैपटॉप कंप्यूटर डिस्टेंस हमने होते हैं
ठीक है इतने पोज होते हैं तो ये पोस्ट
क्या करते हैं जैसे मां लीजिए आपको कोई
कनेक्शन रहना है तब आईपी एड्रेस के साथ
पोर्ट से बनाएंगे क्योंकि हर एक कोड पे एक
डिफरेंट सर्विस रन हो रही होती है मतलब
आपका कंप्यूटर जो है हमारा ये वो एफटीसी
कनेक्ट है साथ में वो ऐसा वेब सर्वर भी
सर्व कर रहा है ठीक है साथ में वो सेट से
भी कनेक्ट है तो वो अगर मैं जो कनेक्शन है
वो अलग-अलग पोर्ट पे अलग-अलग सर्विस हो
रहा है ठीक है ना आपका जो वेब सर्वर है वो
किसी पोर्ट पे आपको वेब सर्विस दे रहा है
तो वहां से आप उसकी कर सकते हैं दूसरे की
सपोर्ट में वो आपको फाइल सीरिंग की सर्विस
दे रहा है वो भी आप कर सकते हैं तो इस
तरीके से कोड जो है लॉजिकल डिवीजन है जी
हर अलग-अलग सर्विस जो है वो रन होती है अब
65000 35 टीसीपी
इंपॉर्टेंट है
ठीक है मोस्टली तो कुछ पोर्ट जो है वो
पुरी डिफाइन होते हैं वेबसाइट नहीं मतलब
इन जनरल होते हैं जहां तक बीजी कम के लिए
सवाल होंगे स्टैंडर्ड का सकते हैं आप उनको
जैसे की वेबसाइट होते हैं 80 80 नंबर 80
ठीक है जैसा कोई वेबसाइट ओपन करते हैं तो
बाय डिफॉल्टर उसका कोड नंबर 80 पे ही ओपन
होता है वो ठीक है ब्राउज़र में अब तो ये
आपकी जो वेबसाइट है वो ओपन हो जाति है
आपके सामने
और इसको मैं आपको दिखता हूं एक लिस्ट टोटल
एफटीपी के लिए
होता है 22 ठीक है जीडीपी के लिए 80
एचटीटीपीएस के लिए 443 असेंबली पर 45 और
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप
ब्लू कम हो गया ठीक है कुछ भी हो गया
इतना पोर्ट नंबर लिखने हैं कोई भी डोमेन
के बाद तो वो सपोर्ट को ओपन करता है तो 80
लिखना हूं मैं ठीक है तो यहां पर ये कोड
नंबर सॉरी
होता है ये देखिए ओपन हो गया ठीक है तो ये
कौन से पोर्ट पर सर्विस चल रही है वही
फोटोग्राफ डालेंगे तो ये कुछ चीज जो है
खुला जाएगी बाय डिफॉल्ट ब्राउज़र में आप
एचटीटीपी खोलने हैं तो हमेशा वो कोड नंबर
80 पर खोलना है और एसटीडीपीएस खोलने हैं
तो हमेशा बोलना है 443 पे ठीक है इस तरीके
से जो है कम है अब अगर आपका मतलब
मां लीजिए आपको एफबी जो है एफबी एक्सेस
करना है तो थोड़ी करेंगे
इस्तेमाल करेंगे जैसे ब्राउज़र आपका जो है
उसे तरीके से ठीक है
ये टूल है ठीक है
इसको इस तरीके से इसके
कनेक्ट करना है तो मां लीजिए मुझे
google.com ठीक है google.com
अब मैं इस पर अपनी एसटीडी पर रिक्वेस्ट कर
सकता हूं क्योंकि मैं आपको नंबर एक्टिव
कनेक्ट किया मुझे पता है की वहां पे एक
वेब सर्वर चल रहा है अभी कैसे पता ये मैं
आपको बताऊंगा अच्छे से कैसे स्कैन होती है
बताऊंगा अभी फिलहाल मुझे ठीक है तो अगर
मुझे करना है तो मैं कैसे करूंगा मैं यहां
पर एक एचडी रिक्वेस्ट भेजूंगा रिक्वेस्ट
कर एक पैटर्न लिख रहा हूं मैं गेट
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा हूं
1.1 का इस्तेमाल करते हुए तो ये भी क्या
चीज होगा समझिए सिंपल ये एक एचडी की
रिक्वेस्ट का जो है फॉर्मेट है
ये मेरे को सर्वर से रिस्पांस ए गया ठीक
है
यहां से मेरा रिस्पांस शुरू हो रहा है ये
रिस्पांस की हेडर्स हैं इस पैकेट हेडर्स
होते हैं ना ये स्पंस की जो है इसमें क्या
चीज है आपको
सही है ठीक है ये डेट के बड़े में दिया
हुआ है कंटेंट टाइप कैसा है और भी चीज जो
है वो साड़ी
पेज जरूर होता है आपके सामने google.com
खोलना पर ठीक है ये वही चीज है कुछ नया
नहीं है इसमें
इस तरीके से जो है मैं कोड नंबर 80 पर
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा हूं
कस्टम रिक्वेस्ट भेज सकते हैं मैंने सिंपल
होम पेज की रिक्वेस्ट भेजी थी वही चीज था
और कुछ नया इसमें नहीं था ठीक है ना तो
वही चीज है यहां पर समझ गए होंगे आप क्या
लिखा है
डिफाइंड
होते हैं तो अंधेरे इसके अंदर करता है अभी
हम उसे करेंगे कुछ डर में और आपको नहीं
बताया बड़े में तो बेसिकली यही था यहां पर
मैं आपको दिखता हूं इधर भी पोर्ट्स के
बड़े में लिखी हुई है ठीक है सॉकेट सॉकेट
क्या होता है ये जो आईपी एड्रेस या फिर
डोमेन नाम कोई भी चीज देख रहे हैं यहां पर
लिखने हैं और कलम लगा के उसके आगे उसका
कोड नंबर लिखने हैं उसका उपयोग करने के
लिए तो इसको ऐसा हो सॉकेट कहा जाता है
सॉकेट कनेक्शन ठीक है ना तो आईबी या फिर
डोमेन और कर्नल के पोर्ट के कांबिनेशन को
हम सॉकेट एड्रेस कहते हैं ठीक है तो एक
सेकंड जरूरी होता है किसी चीज से कनेक्ट
करने के लिए
आईपीएस कनेक्ट
होना होगा ठीक है ना ये होता है
हो गया
है
इसको कंप्लीट कर लेते हैं
हमें टैग करके जो अभी तक एक भी बच्चे का
मुझे नहीं दिखा किसी ने किया भी हो एक भी
आदमी ने ठीक है तो मेरे ख्याल से कोई करना
चाहिए नहीं तो अगर आप नई शेर करना कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है प्लीज इसका स्क्रीनशॉट लेक
डालिए हां ये तो चलिए मैं कल से विप वाला
है जिसके पास अकाउंट है वो करें जिसके पास
नहीं है वो हमारी वीडियो देखने के बाद
आतिश फीडबैक और रिव्यू दे दे ठीक है और
फिर करें क्योंकि पहले अकाउंट ठीक नहीं है
तो कोई बात नहीं हमें कम से कम ग्रुप में
नीचे की मैंने किया है अपने जैसा बताइए
हमें ठीक है नेक्स्ट हमारे लिए स्टैंडिंग
और नेटवर्क
इसमें क्या क्या देख लेते हैं इसमें चलिए
से पहले मेरे ख्याल से आपको मैं आपको चीज
और बता देता हूं पहले ठीक है जैसे नेटवर्क
स्कैनिंग के बड़े में और अपने कुछ दिखाना
चाहता हूं पैकेट तो से ही लिया ठीक है
थोड़ा दिखा देता हूं आपको मैं यहां पर
ये देखिए यहां पर ए चुका है कोई ओपन कर
लेट हूं
वही चीज यहां पर स्टडी
होता है एक्सेप्ट होता है की आप कौन सा
आपको जो ब्राउज़र है वो कौन सा रिक्वेस्ट
कर रहा है कनेक्शन होता है की प्राइमर
कनेक्शन
डीपी के भी रिक्वेस्ट करने की कई सारे
मेथड होते हैं जैसे गेट मेथड है ये यहां
पर गेट लिखा हुआ है गेट मतलब हमें डाटा
चाहिए
होते हैं ठीक है इसके अलावा और भी होता है
ट्रेस होता है ट्रेस से हम जानते हैं की
कौन-कौन सा जो है मेथड वो अलाउड है ठीक है
इस तरीके हेड होता है और ऐसे बहुत सारे जो
है एचडी में मेथड होते हैं उनके बड़े में
आप पढ़ सकते हैं अच्छे से डिटेल में ठीक
है लेकिन ये चीज बेसिक
चिंता नहीं करना है उसके बड़े में
चलिए तो पहले पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग उपकरण से
पहले कुछ चीज और जरूरी है पहले वो मैं
आपको कर देता हूं जैसे की आपको नेटवर्क
स्कैन करना है ठीक है अब से हमने अच्छे
समझ लिया है ये आपको अच्छे समझ में ए गया
होगा की एक जो डिवाइस है ठीक है वो एक
नेटवर्क में कैसे एक्जिस्ट कर रहा है मतलब
उसका आईपी एड्रेस कॉन्सेप्ट कोर्ट का
कॉन्सेप्ट माइक्रोमैक्स सबको समझ में ए
गया होगा मैंने उसे टाइम से समझाया था
पोर्ट भी आपको समझ गए हैं ठीक है समझना की
डिवाइस जो नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट है वो कैसे
एग्जिट कर रहा है की इंजॉय से कनेक्ट हो
सकता है सब कुछ अपने अच्छे से समझ लिया
ठीक है ये चीज आपको समझ में ए गई होगी अब
अगर आप एक नेटवर्क में है जो की आप सिर्फ
नेटवर्क नहीं पढ़ रहे हैं नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी भी पढ़ रहे हैं
हम एक नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट है ठीक है उसे
नेटवर्क की जो डिवाइसेज हैं उनको हम कैसे
स्कैन करें तो उसके लिए कई सारे वेरियस
टूल्स आते हैं ठीक है और पीछे होती है कोई
कोई पिंक पे कम करता है
पूरे नेटवर्क में साड़ी वाला स्ट्रिपिंग
करता है और भी इस तरीके से तरीके होते हैं
चेक करने के ठीक है ना तो बेसिकली कुछ
सॉफ्टवेयर
गूगल करेंगे आपको मिल जाएगा
मेरा आईपी एड्रेस
2017 ठीक है इसको मैं लिख लेट हूं पहले
192.1
तो हमें क्या करना है यहां पर अब यहां पर
एक कस्टम कर सकते हैं आपके ऊपर है तो मुझे
क्या करना है
1990 सबको
यह देखिए
यहां पर
लाइन चालू है
ठीक है
तो इसका उसे कर सकते हैं
स्विच होते हैं वैसे तो लेकिन एक बेसिक
स्विच है दास ए इसका मतलब होता है जो
इसमें काफी चीज जो है जैसे की आपका सर्विस
वर्जन स्कैन करना है भारत केयरिंग करना और
भी हो शक्ति है ठीक है इसका इस्तेमाल कर
सकते हैं पर अभी हम इसका संबंध नहीं
करेंगे अभी हम एक दूसरा सीजन लगा रहे हैं
जो की सन सन मतलब आपको फोर्स करेंगे रॉक
देनी है
बेसिकली पोस्ट करने में करता है ठीक है
आपको अभी भारत नहीं करनी है आपको बस अभी
इतना जानना है की नेटवर्क कितने सारे
नेटवर्क मुझे डिवाइस में कुछ इतने सारे
कनेक्ट है ठीक है ये लिखना है सिर्फ क्या
करना है आपका एक्सपीरियंस देनी है
ठीक है ये मुझे आइसक्रीम है और दास भी
मतलब बस ठीक है
तो इंटर करता हूं इसको देखिए स्कैनिंग
चालू हो चुका है
दास भी आप लगाएंगे
यहां पर यह
भी
आगे बढ़ते हैं
और फिर
करने
हो सकता है
और फिर भी हो सकता है
जैसे की आपके विंडोज में कैमरा देखा होगा
आजकल अगर आप उसको पब्लिक नेटवर्क कनेक्ट
कर देते हैं किसी नेटवर्क कनेक्ट करने के
बाद प्राइवेट क्लिक कर देते हैं तो उसमें
कुछ कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से राहत है
ठीक है
इन सब स्कैन कर सकते हैं
कैसे कम करता है ठीक है
एंड्राइड वन मैं अपने राउटर पर ठीक करूंगा
ओपन है ठीक है 84 नंबर चलिए अब अगर मुझे
सारे
प्रोडक्ट्स दे दूंगा लेकिन वो बहुत लंबा
चल जाएगा 6500 बहुत लंबे हो जाएंगे ठीक है
तो इतना हम स्कैन नहीं करना है तो आखिर कर
सकते हैं
उनको स्कैन करेगा पर दास ही आपका
वर्जन क्या है
ठीक है और क्या नाम है आपका जो आस है वो
कौन सा है तो ये चेक करके क्या करेंगे
वरना वो बहुत टाइम ग जाएगा
क्लोज कर देते हैं
देखने के लिए क्या नाम है कौन से स्टेट
में थोड़ा है उछलना गलती बोल दिया होता है
चेक करने के लिए क्योंकि पैकेट का स्लो
कैसा है ठीक है ऑप्शंस होता है आपका दिखने
के लिए की कौन-कौन से जो है मेथड अलाउड है
ठीक है इसको बेटा कहते हैं
तो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
मैं आपको बताता हूं यहां से पहले ए जाता
है
ठीक है ये लास्ट लैब है इस मोडल का
लेक्चर काफी है ठीक है
ये एक एप्लीकेशन है नेटवर्क एड्रेस टेबल
का ठीक है जो एक कम्युनिकेशन में डायरेक्ट
करने के लिए हेल्प करता है उसका मतलब क्या
है ठीक है इसका मतलब कुछ ये है की जैसे
आपको समझिए ये चीज की आप एकजुम कीजिएगा
आराम से ठीक है ना इसको तू ऐसे मत देखिएगा
वीडियो को अभी इसे समझिएगा आराम से मैं
क्या बोल रहा हूं कीजिएगा मन में ठीक है
आते हैं मैंने आपको कसम में जितनी डिवाइस
कनेक्ट है सबके पास अपना एक एक प्राइवेट
आईपी एड्रेस है मां लीजिए डॉक्टर है उसमें
पांच जो करेक्ट है ठीक है और पांचवी
डिवाइस के पास अपना एक एक पर्सनल प्राइवेट
आईपी एड्रेस है ठीक है लेकिन राउटर के पास
क्या है राउटर के पास अपना एक प्राइवेट
टाइप की एड्रेस भी है और एक पब्लिक टाइप
की ड्रेस भी है जो इंटरनेट सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर ने आपको प्रोवाइड किया है ठीक
है तो आप जब पांचवें डिवाइस में से किसी
भी डिवाइस से कुछ भी सर्च कर सकते हैं
इंटरनेट पर ठीक
भी सर्च करते हैं अगर तो वो जो सर्च आपने
किया है ठीक है वो रिक्वेस्ट राउटर के
थ्रू होते हुए बाहर जाति है और राउटर के
पब्लिक आईपीएस के थ्रू ए जाति है ठीक है
12 आते हैं जो भी कम है वो हो गया पूरा और
फिर रिस्पांस जो है लोट के आता है ठीक है
रिस्पांस लोट के आपकी डिवाइस तक ए जाता है
तब ये जो लोट के आया ये जो पूरा होगा
सुनने में तो अच्छा लगा की वही है ठीक है
रावत आपके डिवाइस से राउटर पे क्या राउटर
इंटरनेट पे क्या इंटरनेट से जो भी
रिस्पांस था वो है आउटर पे और आउटर से
हमारी डिवाइस पे ए गया पर ये हुआ कैसे जब
बाहर वाली जो है इसको पता ही नहीं है की
आप अंदर क्या चल रहा है नेटवर्क के तो वो
कैसे कर दिया मतलब आपने जब रिक्वेस्ट किया
आपने राउटर को ठीक है की मुझे मालूम
google.com दे दो भाई ठीक है इस आईडी पर
सपोर्ट
ने अपने पब्लिक से रिक्वेस्ट किया इंटरनेट
पे तो राउटर रिक्वेस्ट किया है रिक्वेस्ट
डॉक्टर के पास गई तो जो सरवर है वो जो
रिस्पांस इशू करेगा गूगल
अल्टर ने की थी तो राउटर को पास रिस्पांस
तो ए गया अब राउटर को कैसे पता की भाई
मेरे पास 522 कनेक्टर किसको भेजना है ठीक
है तो खाने की तो आप बोल दीजिए की अरे
उसको बताई जाए उसके पास रिक्वेस्ट आई थी
तो ठीक है पता रहेगा तो कैसे पता रहेगा
जैसे आप किसी इंसान को नाम से जानते हैं
तो वो कैसे जानेगा और वैसे आईपीएल पोर्ट
से जान का ठीक है तो राउटर क्या करता है
जब कोई रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है स्टार्टिंग में
जा रही होती है मतलब जैसे डिवाइस ए से मां
लीजिए जा रही है और रिक्वेस्ट आउटसाइड के
लिए है तो वो इस वक्त उसे एंट्री को नोट
कर देता है ठीक है वो सिर्फ सेंटी को नोट
कर लेट है ताकि जब रिक्वेस्ट गया जब
रिस्पांस आया है तो वो वापस से रिस्पांस
को वहीं पर ड्राइव कर दे वो आईपी एड्रेस
और पोर्ट को जो है नोट कर देता है यहां से
मैं रिक्वेस्ट गई है और रिस्पांस आएगा वो
इनके लिए आएगा आईटी रिस्पांस आता है फिर
वहां जो है फॉरवर्ड हो जाता है ठीक है तो
ये कब हुआ ये तो पॉसिबल हुआ है जब आप एक
अंदर नेटवर्क से बाहर रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे
हैं तो आपको बाहर है कम्युनिकेशन तो बन
गया काम का चल रहा है लेकिन तब क्या होगा
अगर आपको बाहर से अंदर का एक्सेस करना है
खाने का मतलब क्या खाने का मतलब ये है की
अभी तो आप नेटवर्क के अंदर बैठे डिवाइस इन
बैठे थे आप इंटरनेट पर कुछ रिक्वेस्ट कर
रहे थे रिक्वेस्ट आउटर थ्रू बाहर गई भारत
का कम हुआ रिक्वेस्ट कैसे चुका है राउटर
ने अपनी टेबल में चेक किया और उसको सही
डिवाइस से पूछा दिया कम हो गया आपका अब
मां लीजिए की आप नेटवर्क के अंदर नहीं
बैठे हैं ठीक है मतलब आपका एक नेटवर्क बना
हुआ है पूरा आपका एक नेटवर्क इसमें पांच
जो है इसका है ठीक है और एक डॉक्टर से जो
इंटरफ्रेंस कनेक्ट है अब जो पांच जो है
उनमें से एक को सर्वर है मां लीजिए रोहित
वेबसाइट रन कर रहा है इसमें का सेट एन हो
रही है और आप इन दुनिया में मुझे अपनी
इंडिया में उसे नेटवर्क को सेट किया ठीक
है और आप चले गए बाहर ठीक है और आप ऐसे कम
बैठे हैं अब आप खुद वेबसाइट को एक्सेस
करना है इंटरनेट के थ्रू तो आप कैसे
करेंगे क्योंकि आप कनेक्ट में आपको
इंटरनेट के थ्रू वो एक्सेस करना है तो
इंटरनेट का थ्रू आप उसको एक्सेस कैसे
करेंगे जब आपको इंटरनेट के थ्रू उसको
एक्सेस करना है मेरे को आपको इंटरनेट के
थ्रू इसको ऐसे करना है जब आप इंटरनेट से
देखेंगे तो आपको समझ में आएगा नहीं उसको
हमको अभी से राउटर दे देना पड़ेगा
मुझे रिक्वेस्ट आई है इसको भेजना
था स्टार्टिंग में डिवाइस भी सेट कर रहा
था कनेक्शन और राउटर पे जा रहा था राउटर
का मतलब की यही से कनेक्शन यही से
रिक्वेस्ट आई है तो रिस्पांस भी यही भेजना
है लेकिन इस बार क्या हुआ की रिक्वेस्ट
बाहर से आई है अंदर वाली के लिए तो बाहर
वाली तो पता नहीं है की अंदर क्या चल रहा
है दूसरा राउटर पे ही रिक्वेस्ट करेगा और
आउटर को पता ही नहीं की रिक्वेस्ट को
भेजना कहां है तो हम क्या करते हैं पहले
से ही हम राउटर में मैन्युअल कैन प्रिंट
सेट कर देते हैं की अगर राउटर के पब्लिक
आईपी पे मां लीजिए पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे कोई
भी रिक्वेस्ट अगर ए रही है तो इसको इस
डिवाइस की सपोर्ट नंबर पे भेज देना तुम
सामने से ठीक है तो इससे क्या होगा की जब
भी कोई सामने देख राउटर के पब्लिक आईपी
एड्रेस के पोर्ट नंबर 80 पर रिक्वेस्ट
करेगा तो हम पहले से उसको बता रखें हैं
आउटर को नेट टेबल में भाई तुमको इसी
डिवाइस है इस को रिक्वेस्ट नहीं है तो फिर
कस्टमर ए जाएगी और फिर रिस्पांस हो जाएगा
वहां से कोई दिक्कत नहीं होगी इस तरीके से
पोर्ट फ्राॅडिंग के जो है कॉन्सेप्ट कम
करता है तो आप समझ गए होंगे एग्जांपल कैसे
मैं कोशिश कर रहा हूं अब मैं इसको जो है
थोड़ा सा एग्जांपल लिस्टेड करके दिखता हूं
देखेंगे हम यहां से वही चीज दी हुई है
साड़ी देख सकते हैं आप ये नेटवर्क के अंदर
आप कनेक्ट है ठीक है
ये वही चीज है बीच में इंटरनेट है आपका
इसको मैं अगर कोई अच्छा डायग्राम मिल जाए
ठीक है
गूगल की कोई इमेज देख लेते हैं हम लोग
साइड है
तो इंटरनेट से राउटर पर रिक्वेस्ट आएगी और
आउटर में हमने पहले सेट कर रखा है अगर इस
पोर्ट नंबर को रिक्वेस्ट आई है तो उसको
डिवाइस नंबर ए बी सी दो और रिक्वेस्ट जो
है इस चली जाएगी तो ऐसे ही जो है कम करता
है तो आपको पहले तो एक चीज की आपकी ये होम
आउटर में ही आता है ठीक है ना ज्यादातर
आपके होम आउटर में ये आता है मतलब आपने जो
डॉक्टर लगाया हुआ है उसमें फॉरवर्डिंग का
एक सिस्टम होगा उसमें से उसको सेट कर सकते
हैं मैं आपको शायद दिखा भी सकता हूं लेकिन
मेरे में है नहीं एक्चुअली
ऑप्शन है पर वो नहीं है तो मैं अपने दिखा
सकता हूं आप जाएंगे सिक्योरिटी जो है वो
टेस्ट में जाएंगे आप राउटर के लॉगिन पेज
पे लॉगिन तो वहां पे जाएंगे तो आपको
कंफीग्रेशन मिल जाएगा तो ये तरीका तो वो
होता है दूसरा होता है एक्सटर्नल किसी
प्रोवाइडर का इस्तेमाल कीजिए ठीक है
एक्सटर्नल पॉइंट करके दिखाऊंगा फिर उसके
लिए थोड़ा चीज आपको और जानी पड़ेगी तो
पहले वो पढ़ लेते हैं
पहले मैं आपको एक छोटी सी दिखता हूं की आप
जेम्स जानते होंगे|
यहां पर ए जाएगा इसका डाउनलोड कर लीजिए
ठीक है लेटेस्ट वर्जन डाउनलोड
ठीक है
यह दो पेज स्टार्ट करने के बाद ठीक है
तो मैंने यहां पर एक फाइल दाल रखा है
इसमें सिर्फ हेलो लिखा हुआ है ठीक है ना
तो ये फिलहाल मैंने यहां पर अपना चालू कर
दिया तो अब अगर यहां पर मैं अपना आईपी
एड्रेस लिखना हूं ठीक है
यहां पर मेरा जो है मेरा नेटवर्क में कोई
भी मेरा सरवर एक्सेस कर सकता है और ये
पोर्ट नंबर 80 पर हो रहा है ठीक है ना ये
मेरा आपकी पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे ठीक है सब कुछ
मेरा रेडी है बढ़िया से
मैंने
दिखाए की अभी ये मेरे नेटवर्क में एक्सेस
हो रहा है लेकिन अगर कोई डिवाइस ऐसा हो जो
मेरे नेटवर्क से अनलॉक कनेक्ट हो ठीक है
ना दें ठीक है
नहीं कर पाएगा तो अगर मुझे इसमें दिखता
हूं यहां पर
ठीक है इसको मैं कट कर देता हूं यहां से
और मैं यहां पर लाकर पेस्ट कर देता हूं
विप ड्रेस चेक करता हूं तो
देख लेते हैं
ठीक है
ठीक है यहां पर बनाएंगे
[संगीत]
और कोई चीज नहीं है इसमें ठीक है
कमेंट लिख दीजिएगा
ओके अब इसको मैं ओपन करता हूं
खाने का मतलब यही वाला दुनिया में कोई
कहानी से भी एक्सेस करना चाहेगा एग्जिट हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो इस तरीके से आप जो आपसे
फुट फर्डिंग कर सकते हैं अब ये एन जी राव
का जो सीन है ये कुछ लिमिटेड फीचर्स है
ठीक है मतलब यहां पर ए गया की कौन-कौन सा
रिक्वेस्ट किया गया है वन जीरो जो है एन
इंटरफेस आता है आपके कुछ ही टाइम तक रहेगा
फिर आपका ये बैंड हो जाएगा बैंड करेंगे तो
फीलिंग बार-बार चेंज होती जाएगी ठीक है और
हैवी ट्रैफिक पे क्लोज हो जाएगी तो ये सब
दिक्कतें होती हैं
मतलब अपने पीछे बात करके अपना जो है आउटर
पे राउटर पे ही सेट कर देते हैं पब्लिक
आईपी एड्रेस
जो है मतलब उसे कर सकते हैं
ये तो एक मतलब
ऐसा कुछ सपोर्ट नहीं दिया गया है और रॉक
वाला जो है एक्टिव नहीं है तब एक और तरीका
समाज दे सकते हैं इसके बड़े में आगे
लेक्चर आपको बताने वाला हूं तो फिर आई समझ
लीजिए
क्या चीज थी क्या मतलब है
बिजली तो पहले हम लोग यहां पर वीपीएन के
बड़े में पढ़ लेंगे ठीक है तो उसके बाद
में आपको एक और तरीका बताऊंगा जो एक बहुत
ही बढ़िया तरीका हो सकता है ठीक है उसके
थ्रू आप किसी भी चीज को अपना मतलब फाइल
सर्वर हो या फिर चाहे आप रिवर्सल ही ना
चाहे ठीक है किसी विक्टर पे आप उसका जो है
एक कनेक्शन अपने लिए इंटरनल मतलब नेटवर्क
से एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क बना सकते हैं उसके
बड़े में हम आगे देखेंगे उसमें थ्रेड को
फिलहाल मैं यहां पर कंटिन्यू करता हूं
तो फार्मर्स के बड़े में जान लेते हैं हम
लोग फरवाल क्या होता है आपको पता ही होगा
सर्वर मतलब एक तरीके से एक बार कम करता है
जैसे इंडियन आर्मी के सोल्जर हमारे लिए एक
बेहतरीन कम करते हैं प्रोटेक्शन करते हैं
हमारी उसे तरीके से फायरवॉल भी होता है
ठीक है ना तो फाइबर क्या करता है
की ट्रैफिक कहां से ए रहा है ट्रैफिक कहां
को जा रहा है ठीक है कौन सी पोर्ट पर ए
रहा है कौन सा प्रोडक्ट हो रहा है ये सब
चीज उसे करता है जैसे बहुत सारे पैकेट के
साथ अटैक हो रहा होगा ठीक है वो चीज चेक
कर सकता है
कस्टम क्राफ्ट
करता है ठीक है ना वही चीज है
यहां पर स्टेटमेंट के बड़े में दिया हुआ
है स्टेटस का मतलब ये होता है की स्टेट
फूल जो होता है ये आपके पूरे कनेक्शन के
ऊपर जो है खाने का मतलब की अगर आपकी
डिवाइस में कोई मेरे से एक्टिविटी की है
तो आपकी डिवाइस को भी ब्लॉक कर देगा ठीक
है और स्टेटस क्या करता है
मतलब डिवाइस मतलब नहीं है अगर कहानी चली
जा रहा है खराब है तो पैकेट रॉक देगा ये
बेसिकली पैकेट को ब्लॉक कर रहा है ताकि कम
कर रहा है सर ठीक है और
लिएi
ठीक है ये कम होता है आपके सर्वर का
क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं वो प्लेयर्स ऑफ ओसी
मॉडल ऑपरेट है
चूंकि ये आपको मैं यहां पर दिखता हूं जैसे
यहां पर
देखिए आराम से ध्यान से समझिएगा ठीक है
एप्लीकेशन
कम हो जाता है ठीक है तो वहां पे डिफरेंस
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन क्या है वह कैटिगरी
इंस्पेक्टर इंटर कनेक्शन पूरा कनेक्शन कौन
देखा है कौन देखा है स्टेट फूल देखा है
ठीक है
पैकेट कौन देखा है स्ट्रैटलेस ठीक है
ह्यूमंस करेक्टली कंसीडर डी फायरवर्क तू
प्रीवेंट डी डिवाइस फ्रॉम ओवरलोडिंग
डिवाइस
फ्रॉम क्रेशिंग डी पैकेट मशीन ठीक है
स्टार्ट करते हैं यहां पर
क्या हो रहा है
ठीक है डेस्टिनेशन
[संगीत]
लॉक हो गया ठीक है और हमारे डिवाइस जो है
इस तरीके से फायरवॉल रूल को आप कंसीडर कर
सकते हैं मतलब बहुत साड़ी चीज मैं रूल
होते हैं ये जनरल पैटर्न भी होता है की
अगर बड़ी हो रही है मतलब पैकेट ज्यादा दे
रहे हैं सब पे भी है और आप ऐसे लोग भी कर
सकते हैं सीधे उसको मैं कमेंट कर देता हूं
ठीक है अब वीपीएन बेसिक ठीक है वीपीएन की
बेसिक बड़े में बात कर लेते हैं थोड़ा सा
हम लोग इसके बड़े में थोड़ा बाथरूम करेंगे
फिर आजकल जॉइंट कर देंगे आगे जो है आगे
कंटिन्यू करेंगे तो वीपीएन के बड़े में आप
जानते ही है वीपीएन क्या होता है
वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क होता है ठीक है
ना एवं क्या होता है वर्चुअल प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क होता है मतलब जैसे
होना चाहिए अच्छे से ठीक है
बाइक इंटरनेट था और आपका इंटरनेट था ठीक
है उन दोनों को आपस में कनेक्ट किया था
ठीक है कनेक्ट तो ऐसे भी थे लेकिन अगर
सामने से वेरी रिक्वेस्ट करना है तो
इंटरनेट से अगर कोई ऐसा कम चला इंटरनेट क
को उसके लिए पोर्ट सोल्डरिंग में कम किया
था ठीक है लेकिन वीपीएन का क्या कम है आप
जैसे मां लीजिए एक आदमी इंडिया में बैठा
है और एक आदमी अफ्रीका में है तो वहां से
बैठे-बैठे 2 नेटवर्क्स को आपस में कनेक्ट
किया जा सकता है इनका इस्तेमाल करके ठीक
है और इसका बेस्ट एग्जांपल ट्री एक ही है
अगर आप ट्रैकिंग इस्तेमाल करते हैं और आप
कीट करते हैं इसमें ठीक है
कीट ने आप अक्सर इसका एक आपको एक ओपनिंग
कंसेंरेशन फाइल मिलती होगी उसके सिर्फ
कनेक्ट करते हैं इनके नेटवर्क में ठीक है
फिर आप इनके नेटवर्क में ए जाते हैं और
इनके डिवाइस को कैसे कर पाते हैं तो वो
वीपीएन का ही एग्जांपल है ठीक है जप्त
एग्जाम अगर आप दे रहे हैं ऐसे और एग्जाम
होते हैं उसमें भी आपको ये होता है ठीक है
उससे कनेक्ट करते हैं और आप उनकी नेटवर्क
में पहुंच जाते हैं तो कैसे आपकी एक अलग
से एक वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क बंता है
जो बहुत दूर तक के डिवाइस को सिम्युलेट कर
सकता है की वो एक नेटवर्क में ठीक है ना
और उससे आपका आंसर कम आराम से कर सकते हैं
ये वीपीएन का बेसिक कम है वीपीएन में मतलब
पढ़ेंगे फिर क्या हम पढ़ेंगे की कैसे
ओपन वीपीएन ठीक है सॉरी ओपन ओपन वीपीएन और
एक वेबसाइट है पोर्टमैन बट आई यू इनका
इस्तेमाल करके हम किस तरीके से
परमानेंट जो है सेट कर सकते हैं पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग ताकि जब तक हमारा डिवाइस ऑन
रहेगा हमारा पट फॉरवर्ड ड्राई का और से
लिंक पे फॉरवर्ड दंगा उससे आप बहुत सारे
कम कर सकते हैं ठीक है इसके अंदर से इसका
इस्तेमाल करते हैं फिशिंग के लिए ठीक है
आपको भी कर सकते हैं लेकिन आपको नहीं करना
चाहिए वो लीगल चीज है ठीक है मैंने बता
रहा हूं किस तरीके से होता है ठीक है ना
और उसका समय क्या है कोई भी जो अपना
इंटरनल पोर्ट है उसका एक्सटर्नल जो है
इंटरनेट पे आप इसको एक्सपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है ना तो उसको प्रैक्टिकल देखेंगे
नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में और आगे फिर बढ़ेंगे और
फिर ये वाला मटेरियल तो कंप्लीट हो जाएगा
फिर हम मूव करेंगे डायरेक्टली नेक्स्ट
मोडल पे ठीक है थोड़ा सा देखेंगे फिर तो
आज के बाद जो क्लास है लेक्चर है इसके लिए
इतना ही रखते हैं उम्मीद करता हूं की
स्टार्टिंग देख लिए होंगे अच्छे से और ये
लेक्चर ये आप अच्छे से देख लेंगे ठीक है
ना तो और करते हैं आज के लेक्चर को यही पे
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में आपसे